I've teamed up with Honda to give my
listeners a chance of a lifetime Honda
wants to send you and a friend of the
2019 Pro Bowl a part part Pro Football
Hall of Fame enshrinement weekend prize
includes round-trip airfare hotel
accommodations and the 4-day diamond
package with elite access throughout the
weekend including the class of 2019
autograph session gold jacket walk
official VIP part is VIP seating at the
concert for legends the enshrinement
ceremony the hall of fame game and more
for more info and to enter check out I
Heart Radio dot-com / re s brought to
you by Honda great deals are waiting for
you now at your local Honda dealer a man
who has sounds like a better package
than I get what is your package Kurt
Warner I don't know I get a lot of
access at the Hall of Fame but that
sound is better than what come on now
hold on a second it's pretty well you're
not part of the 2019 autograph session
because you're already in you've done
the gold jacket walk yes I got okay
you could be invited to whatever a party
you want a VIP seating at the concert
for legends or the legend so you've got
VIP seating hold on a minute
enshrinement ceremony you're now gonna
be I'll be up there you're sitting there
yeah watching everybody right I'm ready
so it's the same game and more but
here's the annual say that the and more
you might not be part of the and more
but you could which is appearing on the
Rich Eisen show at the at the Hall of
Fame I know somebody that could make
that happen oh yeah that's right now you
however in your incredible life and
career are gonna have a first this year
and on Sunday you're calling the Super
Bowl yeah on the radio on Westwood One
yeah that's so cool I know it I mean it
is it's what's amazing is that when you
know you're growing up you know you
think about the playing part of it but
the amazing thing for me is that not
only did it turn into an unbelievable
career on the field but this game has
presented me with tremendous
opportunities off the field you know
afterwards whether it's our show that
we're doing together traveling around
calling games or you know now being able
to call a Super Bowl I mean that's been
you know I'm just I'm so blessed in so
many different ways but it's it's
incredible that I'm sitting here at this
age and knowing that the game has
provided me with some incredible
incredible things yeah the NFL has been
kind enough to let us have the Lombardi
Trophy on the set here and it's sitting
right in between us what what did it
mean to you to lift this knowing again
your story a lot of folks think they
know your story but the amount of time
and effort you took to put in to to
never give in to those who said you
can't all came to a head the night that
you won this in this town right I think
that's the amazing thing was how quickly
things happen for me once I got into the
league and so yeah I mean you dream of
winning that trophy and winning the
Super Bowl and being a part of that but
for me it was it was so much more
because it happened so quickly and it
was that first year that I was starting
and to go on to win the Super Bowl you
know it meant more than even winning the
Super Bowl I think for me because it was
the journey and it was the people that
said you had no chance and it was the
moments that I remember sitting there
with my wife going is it just time to
give up is it time to let the dream go
how else we want to have that chat with
Brenda do you think yeah I don't know if
we had it a lot but we had it a few
times where you know you have those
people that are in your life that want
to support everything you do but they
give you that look like you know I'm
supporting you but come on dude I mean
really it's probably not gonna happen at
this point it's just you know so at some
point you have to let it go I mean you I
think about that with my kids you know
my kids have the dream of playing in the
NFL and doing that and you know I've got
one that's playing in college now and
the brass right at Nebraska and one
that's you know just 14 a freshman but I
just think to myself for most people
that comes to an end at some point and
I've got to be ready as a dad to go okay
it's been great but maybe this is the
end for you and that's how the people my
parents my wife as much as they wanted
to support me and and helped me along
this path I mean you get to be 26 27 and
it's like you know I love you dear and
maybe the thing I have to tell you is
it's time to let it go and
you know and I tell people all the time
that you know they say how do you keep
going you know how do you keep going
when you're working in a grocery store
you're doing that sort of stuff
the funny thing for me was that
everybody looks at sitting on the bench
for four years and getting cut by Green
Bay and going to the grocery store and
all I ever looked at was every time I
played football every time I was between
the lines my one year in college player
of the year in our conference you know
when I played in arena football we went
to two championships I was the best
quarterback in the league when I went to
Europe and so what kept me going was
nobody's ever shown me I've never
stepped on a field and not-being been
able to be successful and so I think
that's what would have just killed me is
had I walked away never given the
opportunity to succeed I didn't want to
be that guy that was 47 years old
sitting on the couch going man if I
would have just got the opportunity I
could have done it so that's what kept
me going was just I need that one
legitimate chance to prove I can play
and thank goodness it came from st.
Louis Rams yeah and then and then came
the opportunity to get playing this game
again here in this town in Atlanta what
was it like for you that week I never
asked you this where again maybe doubts
could have made creeped in again is it
there's a lot of time between arrival
and and kicked off I mean what was it
like for you that week knowing that the
opportunity to capital office look the
interesting thing is at that time there
was no week in between that's right so
it was bang right into Super Bowl so you
really didn't have a week to think about
it it that bruiser against Tampa right
exactly happen on Sunday right and you
turn around it were you in Atlanta by
Monday I can't remember if we left on
Monday because I think you know they had
preparations the week before like if we
win this game here's what we've got
here's what we're gonna do and here's
when we're leaving and all that stuff so
I do believe we left on Monday but the
one blessing of that was you just hand
over all the hotels and tickets and
everything to your wife and you pay you
guys take care of this but the other
crazy thing about that week was at that
time they gave out all the awards you
know for the season the week leading up
to Super right and so what I remember is
that it was
practice and then it was media and then
I had to be whisked over to to some
banquet and you know I got like the MVP
award and so there was so much going on
that week that I was completely
exhausted when they came game came I
remember thinking to myself can we just
get this game over I mean this is the
biggest game of my life and I'm thinking
can we just get this game over with so I
can relax so it had worn me out
throughout the week and you know it was
disappointing because obviously you want
to enjoy it and you enjoy the moment you
enjoy the three hours but as I went back
to the other Super Bowls later on I was
able to take a more of a deep breath and
have a perspective on enjoying the
moment that I'm in because they are so
rare but that first one was really crazy
and I was worn out I was tired because I
just didn't know how to handle it all
being that everything happened so fast
well Kurt Warner here in the Rich Eisen
show of that story some things that
would definitely not happen again
one is know by week that will never
happen again we will always have a bye
week in between certainly now that
they're playing the Pro Bowl in between
and now we also know in terms of for
sure bodies and rest and health and and
just that the week off is a must-have
the fact that you were taken to a
banquet during Super Bowl week is the
quarterback of a team I mean not even
last year night before the game on an
honors night there's no like Brady
wasn't gonna anyway on this green earth
exactly without a very warm other place
freezing over would he have been
presented to accept that award for even
10 minutes with a police escort from the
hotel and back like hey top round trip
Bill Belichick round trip it would be 45
minutes tops
right just dress go and come back yeah
never never you are see you into a
banquet exactly a couple of them
actually and you know the thing is this
that's great I mean it crazy yeah I just
didn't know how to say no I mean I think
now you know like you'll see it at
honors if somebody wins if it's in the
game they'll give you a video you know
from your hotel room but I mean at that
point I I didn't know how to tell
anybody now is like somebody wants okay
great but for me but you have no prob
go I mean I don't even remember what I
said I just know somebody grabbed me and
you know I do remember there was some
police escorts they took us to some
great fast-food restaurants and I got
some nice orange slushies and stuff
along the way they go so that was the
highlight in between all those trips but
but yeah it was it was a crazy crazy
people and now it's amazing here we are
back in Atlanta who's back in the game
the Rams now they're in Los Angeles who
are they getting to face Brady who
obviously won his first at your expense
unfortunately and and here we are again
what are the odds
Brockman I know you're you're the
gambler amongst and you've got now two
NFL drew Network people for whom we are
not allowed that's true that's true is
there a way to put hard-earned American
dollars on the possibility of the Rams
winning this game when the Patriots
attempt to win it ends on the one-yard
line
is there something it could possibly be
Foote that prop that out somewhere and
see who bites or what about a 24-year
old quarterback winning on a last-second
kick the last play of the game there's
another one to go would be the odds of
that I mean Brady was 24 when he beat us
and now here's an office 24 and now they
win on a kick which is it was the first
game in Super Bowl history to end on a
kick the last play of the game so come
on that's one story line we have yet to
even think of in terms of a parallel and
gulfs went from Cal Vince Ferragamo was
the last Los Angeles ramp quarterback of
this game went to Cal okay they're
wearing the same sort of heaven can wait
Warren Beatty type throwback uniform ol
year was the last year we wore those
uniforms are you serious well not the I
guess a Patriots I'm the one in Atlanta
then we changed to nothing more st.
Louis II well you're only have our own
our own colors at that point so that was
what do you think of this game let's
break it down what do you got for me on
this front well you know me I could give
you eight million different things I
tell you what sit here and say what's
the one key knowing that there's ten but
I
I mean I'm excited about this game I
mean uh you know I mean Brady against
the pass rushers of the Rams I think
that's fascinating because anytime you
want to be Brady you have to get
pressure on it you're not gonna get
pressure on him it's it's gonna be a
long day and not to scheme your way to I
mean four sets of hands and the dirt may
be certainly pushing up the middle
that's the key yeah a push up the middle
you can scheme different things to get
that put but you're right I mean but but
that's the key right is we got sue and
Donald out the middle I mean the two big
guns for the the Rams are up the middle
and that's that is the key because
Brady's not gonna beat you by escape in
the pocket like a Patrick mahomes he
doesn't want to go out of the pocket so
that is the key so I'm fascinated by
that side of it
the other side well you know what the
Patriots are so good at scheming what do
you scheme to take away I mean are they
gonna take away the run game and allow
opportunities down the field and the big
plays but I'll tell you what rich what I
really when I watch the Rams offense I'm
interested to see if the Patriots do the
exact same thing they did to us in that
game 17 years ago beat the crap out of
the running back well and but the
running back here is not as prevalent in
the passing game but beat the heck out
of the wide receivers
if they can is get physical with two
smaller type wide receivers on the
outside that they like to stretch the
field and get down the field with them
are they gonna beat them up are they
gonna grab them are they gonna get
physical Stephon Gilmore he's a physical
corner when you watch them against the
Chiefs that's what they did is these
guys are fast we got to slow him down
early and we got to create pressure and
I I'm interested to see if they go the
same sort of route against the Rams this
time that they did too to start this
over
so what does McVeigh do to counter cuz
this is the thing that I'm very much
looking forward to seeing these two guys
right the the the modern-day Lombardi
against somebody who in the first hour
Steve Smith says has an opportunity at
age 33 freshly 33 making this Super Bowl
and obviously having an impact on the
league to the point of other hires and
we're seeing similar formations being
put together
he thinks that McVeigh could have a
similar Bella check type impact based on
the way that this young career has
started what do you think about yeah I
mean yeah that the response no I'm not
ready to put any I mean what the
Patriots have done is I don't think
we're ever gonna see that again so I'm
not ready to put anybody in that
category but you know fascinating things
that the Rams do formations in motions
you know when you're talking about a
team that plays a lot of man-to-man
coverage the hardest thing to do is when
a guy goes in motion and you snapped the
ball when he's behind the quarterback or
he's running a jet sweep and you're
trying to play man-to-man coverage for
that guy to be able to chase that guy to
the other side of the field and so with
all the movements that they do how does
that counter what the Patriots gonna do
how does that counter if they want to
play a lot of man-to-man coverage the
other thing is now Todd Gurley is has
called a lot of passes the last couple
years in this offense they haven't
necessarily used him in a lot of route
running but that's another area where I
think the Patriots are vulnerable is if
they're gonna play a lot of man-to-man
coverage
covering backs out of the backfield I
mean Alvin Kamara had 11 catches last
week and it just seemed like they could
go to him all day long if they wanted to
will there be something in this game
plan from Sean McVeigh using Todd Gurley
in a novela question using Todd Gurley
in the passing game in a different way
try to stretch the field or get some
matchups on a Hightower or one of those
linebackers that we haven't seen before
and so those are some things that I'm
looking at because you know I just
fascinating of how the Patriots like to
play and how they I can see them
attacking this you know Shaun McVeigh
type offense but some of the counters
that that show might come up with a few
minutes left here with Kurt Warner pound
the table for Isaac Bruce whose name we
might hear Saturday night to join you
and Kenton I mean all I can been around
a lot of great players great receivers
you know guys like Larry Fitzgerald
that'll be a first-ballot guy
Anquan Boldin Torry Holt greatest route
runner I've ever seen play this game you
know that starts it cuz I've played
against it in and with a lot of great
ones but to me the hardest thing is as
you know as you move farther into this
thing the stats of our game have gotten
outrageous but when Isaac Bruce retired
he was only the second receiver that it
reached 15,000 yards in his career I
mean only him and Jerry Rice we nee
retired what at that stage now I mean
they're still only I think five guys
that have done that and so I think he's
gotten overshadowed by some of these
guys that were on individual teams but
what I think we have to remember is how
great Isaac was before the greatest show
on turf because we put everything it
together with the greatest show on turf
and what he gave up still being a great
receiver but I mean we had Marshall and
we had Torrey and we had you know we had
Oz and we had all these guys that he had
to share the ball with had that guy been
on a team where he was the main guy his
whole career I think we're talking about
a guy that's right there with Jerry Rice
in terms of yards and what he
accomplished I just think that gets
overshadowed a little bit because it was
an unselfish team where everybody got
touches but he still ranks you know top
15 in catches still ranks top 5 in yards
it's time to get that guy in and you
know and then you could go beyond that
and off I mean I think of Hall of Fame
and I don't just think of numbers I
don't just think of stats I think of how
you carry yourself what you meant to an
organization and what you meant to the
league and there's nobody that carried
themselves better than Isaac Bruce that
represented this league better than him
you couple that with the stats I think
he should be a slam dunk to be in the
hole well we'll find out on honors on
Saturday night and obviously we'll talk
about our on game day morning on our
pregame show that starts at 9:00 a.m.
Eastern Time I includes a lot of this
X's and O's Chad and I are you aware of
the piece that I'm shooting on Saturday
to air on Sunday okay I am going to
start promoting my run at the comp okay
on Rich run on behalf of st. Jude I'm
going to run at the NFL Super Bowl
experience you argue to run I am on
Saturday on Saturday I unveiled that one
time I do but I have to make an
exception this time because the person
who I'm running either with or hopefully
not against is Usain Bolt
Wow don't clap yet' yeah yeah I don't
know what you guys are clapping it's
gonna be a long day Sunday when we watch
that video holy cow it says eight and a
half hours we get to talk about you
getting no I think it'll be later
whenever noon we might focus a little
bit more on something more the supersoul
leading up is this like is it gonna be
like I feel like it's gonna be like
rocky cuz I know you're training are we
gonna have like you out in the rain and
the snow and chasing the rooster yeah
and I mean is it gonna be a whole thing
and then we get to the race and they
don't show us the end of the race until
hitting hitting frozen meat hung on the
bus yeah I mean I know you've been
training for it this year so we need to
see training video yeah nothing else you
better get that ready for the comp no
I'm I'm I'm doing it I don't know if
you've noticed but I mean I've sorry I
didn't but I will notice if you beat
Usain Bolt I don't know I will notice
that I don't expect to beat him I don't
know I don't know what to expect right
but um it's setup he's more of a hundred
200 guy I mean in 40 you might be able
to get him in you know as you know I
have short bursts early speed I've got
very sure but this skirt loves when I
try physical challenge there's no sir I
really love that I cannot wait for that
video I can't wait till Sunday I'm I'm
even more excited I mean I was thinking
about eight and a half hours then I
gotta call the game for three yeah yeah
what are you gonna do it's gonna be a
long day but now that will help break it
up give me a little extra energy I'm
looking forward to that at curt 1313
warner on both Twitter and Instagram
love you Curt thanks for coming here
Kurt Warner here on the Rich Eisen trip
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience